the world of my hero academia is one
that is still largely unexplored at the
very start of the series we saw that the
first quark user was a shining baby from
China but after this moment the main
series never ventured outside of Japan
again however thanks to the vigilante
spin-off manga and the two heroes movie
there is one other country that's
managed to get a decent amount of screen
time for those that don't know horikoshi
is a massive fan of American comic books
and his favorite hero is actually
spider-man who made a brief cameo in the
first chapter of my hero it was this
love of American heroes that led to the
creation of all might who's red white
and blue color scheme as well as his
general demeanor it's pretty comparable
to a stereotypical Western hero also his
moves are literally named after American
states but you guys already knew that
one in this video we'll be examining a
few things so first I'm gonna take you
through everything there is to know
about hero Society in the USA including
the fact that the freakin Avengers are
actually Canon in this universe I'll
also explain the numbers based reason
why I genuinely believe that an American
spin-off will happen sooner than you
think and finally we'll go through the
three most realistic ideas on what a
spin-off manga in America should or will
look like just before we get into it
though this channel is on that long road
to 100k so I would really appreciate it
if you guys would subscribe okay so in
vigilantes we got a bit of a history
lesson about the origin of quarks and
America's role in creating the first
legalized hero system quite early on in
the main series all might briefly
mentioned how when quarks first
manifested society was thrown into a
state of chaos which is something that
villains like all-4-one used to their
advantage what all might didn't mention
though was that during this time regular
people became vigilantes to maintain
some law and order in society these
vigilantes weren't governed by any hero
association but instead they were just
regular people with quarks obviously and
they were doing whatever they could to
protect their community in response to
this it was the state of Rhode Island in
the u.s. that was the first place to
introduce a hero licensing system and
before these rules came into effect
there were 189 vigilantes in
the state but after the law was passed
just seven of them met the criteria to
become legal heroes what this meant is
that 182 vigilantes were now in the eyes
of the law release they were considered
to be villains due to their illegal
quirk use that's the way it was and
apparently the main factor in
determining who would become a hero was
popularity but moving on to modern-day
America we learned some more facts about
the present-day hero system due to
captain celebrity who is the number one
hero in the country this is a character
introduced in vigilantes and he had a
lot of lawsuits against him and was
stripped of his hero license it was
because of this that he moved to Japan
and something that caught my eye is that
when the whole situation was resolved
and he was able to go back to the u.s.
his manager said that his license would
be reinstated in specific States so her
wording implied that heroes don't get
one license that allows them to operate
in all 50 states but rather it's kind of
like you have to apply for a license or
a state-by-state basis this does make
sense but it's very different from the
Japanese system in which once you have a
license you can literally just roam
around the entire country doing hero
stuff as certain Pro heroes actually
prefer to do the last thing to mention
on this is that the existence of a
license structure it kind of suggests
that quirk usage for regular American
citizens is generally not allowed much
like in Japan hero licenses exists so
that the professionals can use their
quirks to maintain order and regular
people can't really use their powers in
most situations clearly this is contrary
to the right to bear arms but the
vigilantes manga does admit that it's
still a topic of debate but as it stands
currently it seems that yes most people
can't really use their quirks freely but
with that said let's transition back
into the real world for a second in
terms of sales the main series has been
absolutely dominating in the US for the
last few years in fact back in February
eight of the top 20 selling graphic
novels in the country were volumes from
my hero academia which shows an insane
demand without giving away any spoilers
vigilantes seems to be in its final art
and it's likely that it will come to an
end in the next few months bearing that
in mind in Chapter 58 we saw that an
Avenger
style tower does exist in New York and
that kind of maybe means the Iron Man is
still alive in the same way that this
manga was used to introduce new
locations new characters and also to
flesh out professor Iowa's backstory I
believe that when you consider the
popularity of this universe in the US
and the foreshadowing that's there and
horikoshi love of American heroes all
reasonable logic would indicate like if
you had to pick something an American
based spin-off would be the logical
sequel to vigilantes obviously there are
1 million ways you can do this for
example you could have a prequel set way
back when there were only 7 licensed
heroes in the world or alternatively you
could do that Avenger Star sequel in New
York although I think Disney's lawyers
might have something to say about that
one there are three concepts that I
think would be best for a spin-off
series in America and I think they would
also stay within the realm of what has
been set up so it'd be quite realistic
if either of these were to happen so far
in the main series we've been heavily
focused on the growing pains of the
coming a hero in Japan but what if we
had an American spin-off purely from the
perspective of licensed Pro heroes
similar to vigilantes I think it would
be great to have another trio of heroes
only this time they all come from
different states and a maid to form a
specific team for a specific mission
what would make this even better is if
all the heroes were of significantly
different standing in hero society
so maybe you have captain celebrity
who's obviously the number one hero and
then you also have a kid who's just
graduated from hero school so he's
probably like 18 around my age and then
on top of that you have a veteran who's
not that well-known so sort of like a
grand Torino type character that way
you'd have a lot of different
contrasting approaches on how to deal
with the mission at hand and I think if
it's done right it could be pretty
hilarious we already know that things in
the USA work differently as Captain
celebrity was sued by one of the
villains that he had defeated which is
something that will never ever happen in
Japan this spin-off could be an
opportunity to explore that side even
more how the culture is so different
especially maybe they're sleazy side of
things let's be honest people would we
be surprised if heroes were taking
bribes from politicians to endorse them
or perhaps being hired to use their
quirks in my creative ways to facilitate
voter suppression stuff like that
things like that would definitely happen
if pro heroes were real and I feel it
would add an element of truth that would
differentiate it from the main series
next up we have the idea for an all my
prequel set entirely in the States which
would be amazing for so many different
reasons young all might is someone who
we definitely have not seen enough of
over the years and I get it because
we're learning about deku story and
about how he becomes a great hero but
I'd personally love to see how the
symbol of peace became what he became a
spinoff dedicated to all my time in
America would be super popular in my
opinion at least what true fan wouldn't
be at least a little bit interested as
to what he got up to during his time in
the u.s. I want to see him in every
single state that he's got a smash named
after like what was he up to in those
states who was he finally against and
why earlier I mentioned how vigilantes
was able to flesh out aizawa's backstory
but what I didn't say was that it did so
in a way that has direct repercussions
for the main anime and manga in a
similar way this all my prequel could
have plot twists and reveals that
directly tie into the present-day
especially regarding the connection
between one for all and all for one not
to mention that America and superheroes
goes hand in hand like you could
potentially if it got the green light
you could have some cameos from Kiros
like Captain America or iron man or
spider-man or maybe like the discount
versions of them I think this series
would fill in the gaps in terms of
certain things in almost past like for
example we have no idea how long he was
actually in America and it will also
serve potentially he could show us what
was happening over in Japan at that time
with Gran Torino being by himself you
know those are so many interesting
things that we could find out about and
in my opinion at least this is the one
that I would like to see the most
however the final idea is perhaps the
most appropriate for a sequel to
vigilantes and that is to have a
spin-off focusing on American vigilantes
what if there was a character who in the
same way that knuckleduster was
obviously inspired by Batman what if
there was a character who was clearly in
the same way inspired by spider-man I
think that would be very well received
by fans but also by the man himself this
could be set during the time period when
Captain celebrity returns to the USA and
he could encounter yeah
more vigilantes getting in the way of
his hero duties a series like this would
have a good follow through with its
predecessor as you know you have cancer
celebrity being the thing that ties them
together and eventually you know maybe
it could lead to more vigilante
spin-offs all across the world if you
think about it like the original series
has introduced us to the concept of
American heroes American hero rankings
all these different things so this
second spinoff set in America that could
introduce us to European African and
South American heroes I think a
vigilante cinematic universe well I
guess it's not cinematic the vigilantes
Maggie universe I think that would be
super cool but anyway guys those are my
three ideas for a spin-off series in the
United States do let me know which you
would most like to see if we had to pick
from those three and don't be afraid to
drop down any ideas you have below as I
do try to read every comment for those
of you that haven't seen it I did a
video last week on what the next
generation of UA could look like so do
be sure to check that one out if you
haven't already peace out